now obviously or even stillness is a new
thing for you kind of learning if you're
going along and do your brilliant job at
it but you've had new stuff on Game of
Thrones as well haven't you in season
two you had fight scene as well that you
had to do the choreography for what was
that life it was that was great actually
that's one of the that's probably some
of the most fun I've had on on Game of
Thrones was learning that fight sequence
it was something I'd never done before
and again that's one of the great things
about the job is that you're you know
they make sure you're trained up and all
these things that you would hopefully
never need to use in real life but that
it's just quite cool to have in our
horse riding and fight training and and
so yeah it was it was I mean I'm no
dancer well I mean I can you know I can
throw a few shapes in a club
or in a bar but I'm gonna give me a
dance routine I'm terrible and that's
essentially what what film fighting is
you know and you've got to make sure
that no you're doing all the right steps
in the right order their eyes someone
can genuine you get hurt um but it was
brilliant you know we got there in the
end and I I just stressed out about it
for weeks and then I think it comprised
of about sort of seven seconds worth of
footage in the actual episode but it's
certainly something I'd love to do more
of and get better at you know you see
someone like Nikolaj who plays Jamie and
he's you know he's done a lot of that
kind of thing in the past and you see
his work on set he rarely uses his stunt
double you know a lot of it is his own
working it's great it's really cool it's
cool to be learning new things I think
all the time isn't absolutely there were
a couple of actors on the show last year
Andy Kendrick in Thomas Sangster who
played the Joker and play the reed Jojen
and Meera and they got to go and that's
going to learn how to skin rabbits yeah
it's brilliant
incredible the things you're learning on
that show I mean if you had to get
bumped off on Game of Thrones there's so
many people have gone by the way they
don't Lea how would you like to go out
hmm it's a good question something that
involved like really I'd like a fight
with a dragon and to be great cuz what
my losing so we're dragging it use any
face you know if another person kills
you that's you know that's kind of your
own fault but dragon shame
no Knights all what's been the kind of
most outstanding I'm striking things
that you've seen on the show everyone on
the show has been the whole series is
kind of geared towards the red wedding
that's what everyone's been excited
about what everyone ever wanted to read
the scripts for everyone wanted to see
the you know the final results of it so
and I you know I've heard all about I
hear it caused quite the stir in the
states and over here but me so far I
mean I think the Battle of Blackwater in
series two was just it's just incredible
I sort of sat there watching it in was
was going you know I've it's like
watching a you know a huge blockbuster
movie and this is and this is television
this is what they call television these
days it was there was something else
what's it meant to you to be part of the
show like that because we most of our
stuff is over in Belfast and we're kind
of just getting our heads down often
shooting and incredibly on glamorous
locations innocence of sodden wood
somewhere in Northern Ireland you know
you you lose sight of what a huge show
it is and what an how its massively
popular and at bay but in a nice way you
know we sort of feel like this a little
bit disconnected from it all you know we
just get on with our work and have a
good time you know have a few beers in
Belfast while we're cracking on with it
and then and then you know you wait and
you see you see all the all the
advertising and the hype when when the
show finally comes out and is just it's
just brilliant to think that this is
just like a group of friends you know
over in Ireland and and and and suddenly
it's this show that's loved the world
over it's been great and and and I think
with everything when when something is
so popular you only really get a full
sense of it I think once the show's
finished or at least once it's finished
for you and a bit further down the line
you want to see how well a show dates or
how you know whether it's kind of an
enduring one you know people are still
watching the wire and having you know
it's and you wonder if Game of Thrones
is going to be the same it's still the
same thing with skins for me I still
don't think I fully am able to
appreciate the impact of that show had
and how far travelled it was and they're
probably the only thing you know from
I only realize if one day in arms of I'm
35 and I'm an interview and someone if
people are still talking about skins
down then it will really hit me but you
know you just you just get on with it
you just take each year as it comes what
you think about that coming back it's
coming back for its final ever series
issue isn't yeah I mean I think um I
think it's gonna be really good um I
think I do think it sort of has to be as
well because you know if you're gonna
send something you know you've got a
this is the last time we will ever see
skins and so you know everyone's are
really willing it to be great from what
I've heard it is you know they've picked
three brilliant characters to revisit in
Effie cook and cassia and and from what
I gather because you know I'm friends
with all three of them you know they
have a very different vibe to skin you
know I think I think fans of the show
are gonna want a certain type of episode
but I think I'm not sure if viewers
always necessarily know what they really
want and you can't you couldn't revisit
those characters inhabit be like an old
skins episode it's definitely they're
gonna they've all grown up and I think
the style of style of filmmaking has to
grow up with them as well and I think
that's what it's I think that's that's
how it's going to appear and I think it
should be really interesting I can't
wait to see that talking what people
want to see out there what are you
looking forward to with season 4 Game of
Thrones and also you've got your film
that you've done monsters dark continent
and sounds Clippers well I haven't you
know I'm really looking forward to
southcliffe you know I was a huge fan of
Martha Marcy May Marlene which was Sean
his last project and and so having
worked with him you know I'm just such a
fan of the way he goes about his his
business and he shoots in such an
interesting way and such and in such a
way that is it's so actor friendly I
always I'm always kind of surprised at
how how rare it is to get a film set
where everything is geared towards the
actors giving the best performance
because although everyone's job is so
important you can see with these the
lists of credits at the end of the end
of things just how many people it takes
to
to make to realize something by the end
of the day if the actors don't deliver
it's not going to be any good and so to
find yourself in a situation where that
is the priority of the director and
therefore everyone on set was was so
refreshing it was great and and I can't
wait to see how it sort how it all fits
together because again it's kind of like
Game of Thrones that everyone's stories
were kind of disparate so you know you
shot your own things and then you had
very little interaction with a lot of
the other actors you know I had a few
scenes with Rory Kinnear
a few with Jeff Bell but in terms of
Eddie Marsan and Shirley Henderson and
the rest I you know I didn't really have
an awful lot to do with them so it's
gonna be really interesting seeing how
it all fits together and what their work
looks like in the same way that yeah on
Game of Thrones you you meet these
people over in Belfast you become really
good friends with them come back to
London hang out with them for nine
months and then see the show and go oh
my god you're you're really good at it
don't you just don't you just notice and
like I guess Thrones you've got great
various great writers on the Tony
Cressona Houston south coast great
writer - yeah a fantastic writer and I
think it's just well everything about it
and when I first heard about the the
project and my agent found incidentally
so and Shaheen Baig is casting and that
that's always the really good sign she
casts great stuff you know all right
good
it's a new four-part drama for channel 4
or being made by warp Wow great really
written by Tony Bruce only fantastic
directed by Sean Durkin you're like
Jesus life I mean and I didn't think I
was gonna get the job at all I was I'm
won't I'm so surprised I got it but
obviously over the moon and I just think
it's got pedigree running right through
it and and then and it to that having
haven't got the job myself then channel
4 made the announcement about the rest
of the cast list and you're like Jesus
Christ it's just like BAFTA winners and
then me mium Kaya Scodelario but yeah it
was really good and I hope I hope it's
as good as you know I think it's gonna
see you're looking forward to it and
monsters as well monsters as well again
some of the we just had such a brilliant
time doing that over in Jordan and then
Detroit and and that was a job that
really it was one of it that we made a
very different film to
one I think we were initially gonna make
and in the best possible way
it took you're just over this really
different turn there was one day on set
where one of the actors Kyle so like
just just gave this room just did this
tape that was just out of this world and
it really no it you didn't really get
this feeling onset of everyone going
okay
so that's the that's the standard we're
going for here and that's the atmosphere
we're trying to create in it and so
whilst it's um you know it's gonna be
quite different to the first monsters
which I think essentially was a love
story more than anything and the
monsters are kind of more metaphorical
in my head and monsters a metaphorical
again in this one I would say but it's
more it's more of a movie about
friendship and it's it's a war movie but
without it being too bombastic it's
actually it's really quite visceral and
it's about this nice bunch of lads from
Detroit who were actually really good
friends who signed up to the army and
head off out to the Middle East to fight
monsters but you know doesn't always go
to plan you've got so many fantastic
things going on now if you could have
anything happen for Gendry in season 4
were would you take him if you could say
yeah I want to do that somewhere hot
great anywhere you know just like
Braavos or you know just anywhere
basically anywhere where flippin
Daenerys has been for the past like
three years because Amelia is always
checking off the you know Morocco or
Croatia or ever and it's you know it's
time to share a bit of sunshine I think
you know Syrio Forel is he's still alive
and jaqen H'ghar you could all get
together back in high very that and just
very lit and this is just a theory like
this all because we don't know anything
that Syrio Forel it is jack and hagar
whoever this that maybe that makes sense
for i wouldn't it watch out for that
hang ya never know and defends out there
what you got to say to them hi and and
and thanks for taking an interest in my
work I'm like I'm quite I quite so not
Precious about what I do but you know I
really sort of believe in everything I
do
if you guys like it and that's that's
telling me that I may be doing something
right and I also need to apologize for
how how boring I am on Twitter I'm aware
of it and whether it changes or not I
don't think it will but stick with me
thanks
you